I tend to go back to the Yaxchilan
largely because I'm so fond of the place
I suppose almost every year for about
forty years or something
in those days to get there you had to
or you almost had to
fly into a
an air field
on the banks of very close to the
banks of the Usumacinta quite a long
way
up river
and then rely on finding
a boatman who could
take one there and back
because there was no other way of getting
there really
but now there's are roads and regular
boat traffic to take tourists there
so it's
also a site that's protected and funded
by the world monuments fund
so it gets a lot of attention
there are tourists that come in boatloads
every day so we'll be
contending with a little bit of tourist
activity at the same time. It's not a
unknown, remote place that you have to chop
to get to it’s you know there are paths
it’s green there's a lot of forest
cover
but there are places that
the normal tourist doesn't climb to where
there are inscriptions and monuments and so
we'll probably get up to some of those spots
and try to
work up there away from the general traffic
of course it's very exciting to be using a
new technology
I expect my notes will be a little bit out of joint
because I won't be using my normal system
I am quite interested in one particular
item
there was a
a very small
stairway and when I say small, it's only two steps
but it's quite wide
and I don't think anybody's ever recorded it
before
so that's something I'm looking forward to.